It's very interesting [I] was worth
about over a million dollars when I was 23 and
Over ten million dollars when I was 24 and over a hundred million dollars when I was 25
and
it
Wasn't that important?
Because I never did it for the money
I
think money is wonderful thing because it enables you to do things it enables you to invest in ideas that don't have a
Short-term Payback and things like that, but
Especially at that point in my life
It was it was not the most important thing the most important thing was [the] company
The people the products we were making what we were going to enable people to do with these products
So I didn't think about it a great deal, and I never sold any stock and just
Really believed that the company would would do very well over the long term